yes maryjean came in earlier she was
pushing her bosoms against the windows
yes we realized we had to a lot of times
we wait until after the commercial to
bring people in but when they're showing
their nipples in the hall we can't have
to bring them in right away so yeah I'll
get in trouble
Yeah right I think you wanted it near my
mouth you wanted to say something to
Travis it's better than Troy's well
welcome
welcome Mary Jean thank you for having
me good morning hi Sam hi Jim hi Troy
I'm so you hi hi I was watching your
Instagram stories and you were coming in
now were you driving or someone driving
you I was driving they're saying someone
kidnapped you yeah some guy kidnapped me
last night
at 12 o'clock and I was with him till
like 7:00 a.m. and I'm like listen I
gotta go I have somewhere to be how did
he kidnap you he told me come to Queens
or Long Island City Queens I was like
okay so I went and I was kidnapped but
how did that sounds right now boy these
dusters he's still with me he won't let
me go it sounds like somebody asked if
you would come to their place and you
said yes that's not Thai kidnapping so
hotel and we drank smoked some weed
passed out and then I no intercourse no
intercourse come on no sex like
masturbate no we slept naked it's only
right because we have I did but it was a
little soft
he couldn't get I don't know me like
sexually so Oh No if he doesn't see you
sectional sexually why is he nude to
hotel yeah why did he bring you back to
his hotel so you guys could sleep nude
together and do drugs yeah I don't know
we does not drugs Sam you know no you're
right I was simplifying yeah and we
drink tequila and I thought he's gonna
get really horny this time this is my
third time hanging out with Nek he
doesn't get horny at all didn't get
horny at all and he did a little bit and
then it went self again you didn't want
to go to his his his Terrace apartment
[Laughter]
this week you've been a little busy
yeah busy busy busy right well
in Los Angeles but I noticed you were
unfortunately which was a shock to a lot
of us you were a little tardy this
morning um three minutes late
three because I thought you said 9:30
meant really 10 o'clock so in my mind I
was like as you asked is 9:30 mean 10:00
last time it was a nightmare he is
actually 9:30 yeah next time I'll get it
down I swear now we're gonna have to
start saying nine o'clock he thinks 9:30
means 10 so nine o'clock would mean 9:30
right it sounds like everyone's [ __ ]
yes okay all right what series fair so
the guy couldn't get a rod no has he's
still soft downstairs why is he still
down straight what do you want I don't
know he wants to go to the dream hotel
and lay by the Sun but he doesn't know I
spray tan I don't lay out and bake right
you got [ __ ] to do I have stuff yeah I'm
filming this week for reality kings and
so weeks I was actually just talking to
handsome Rob during the break about how
disappointing it would be to have the
conversation that I had with Mary Jean
with somebody that you had like a girl
you had a crush on right yeah because
you know you said to Mary so when are
you traveling and Mary said Oh tomorrow
yeah and I said Oh Mary where are you
headed to and she was like I'm going to
Miami to shoot for reality at Fort
Lauderdale to shoot for reality kings
and it made me think like how if I was
like fight a crush I'm Mary Jean right
now I'd be so disappointed there's a
point like oh no anything I want your
dick to get hard because I have new
material coming out and then I said
you're not gonna have an intercourse are
you and she went like this oh wait I
think I forget some time what I really
do then wipe the Dominican Republic
after there's a sex party going on and I
got invited and I go yeah way it's gonna
be exciting I'm gonna have two girls for
myself and supposedly I get to walk them
on a leash on everything so I'm pretty
excited it sounds fun to go to the
Dominican Republican walks in a leash
yeah that's a great weekend I think
that's that two girls for every boy I
think that's what that song was yes the
Dominican Republic yeah I've never been
to a sex party I think I don't know how
I'd handle it do you not get invited I
don't know maybe they'd be weirded out
I'd be uncomfortable I wouldn't do well
it's already I'm excited I have my
bathing suit picked out and everything
naked I'm most likely I well okay well
you wear a bathing suit there
and then eventually you get naked yeah I
see something like I don't know I never
want someone before I like that is it a
is it a smart one piece now it's a smart
two piece is that does it leave a lot to
the imagination
not really I see this is risque always a
my goodness so why is this guy I don't
understand why this man is downstairs
waiting for you he still stairs yeah he
told me he's a big fan of your show I'm
like you better I couldn't get an
erection everybody's hard listening to
you right yeah now the fact that he's a
fan of the show does that mean when he
goes to the strip club you charge him
extra money of course and he was to come
visit me always I actually had a fan
last week he goes oh my god you're like
on the street reporter for Jim Lauren
and Sam Roberts show and I was like okay
a hundred dollars per song two dances I
earned 200 like wow what up remember I
Texas yes do you know that that's Mary's
philosophy that a lot of people are like
you know they'll come on and promote
their business say if you say that you
heard about me on this radio show here's
a discount sure for Mary she said it
makes her feel like a celebrity so if
you are out at the club and you see Mary
Jean and you want to get a dancer there
and you tell her I know you from Jim
Norton and Sam Roberts show charge you
much place you just draw laughter tell
Mary Jean after you get the dancing hey
by the way I know you did a street
report if I have not heard any of it
right well we will get to that okay
is the sex party just one evening it's
two days out in Dominican Republic the
48 hour sex party it's a 48 hour sex
party and I don't know there's gonna be
two football players so I'm thinking big
black dick and I'm ready okay have you
been preparing yourself for that Kegel
exercises no I haven't because I'm gonna
be shooting two days before so I think
my [ __ ] is gonna be stretched out just
a little bit slightly okay how many
different scenes on two different scenes
I'm gonna have one threesome the other
one just regular threesome with a girl
and a guy yes now will you be doing anal
in the scenes no you know just yet
just yet okay yeah no not you
done that on camera not yet right I
heard a name on camera no I'm waiting
I would love to lose my [ __ ]
virginity camera thing whatever you want
to call it for browsers because they're
so great I don't love that company so
that's on the table please yeah are you
afraid there'll be a little mistake or
an accident no I'm gonna starve myself
maybe for two days aren't like doosh
back there or do they call it an enema
yeah by the way I did something I did
this dinner thing where I was shooting a
pilot where I have dinner with for porn
stars huh and I ate with them and they
were talking about anal scenes and they
said the girls eat gummy bears before
because gummy bears dissolve and you
pissed them out you don't [ __ ] them out
and they give you a sugar rush see how
high you're not hungry
laney actually told me about yeah but
you don't [ __ ] them out you piss them
out huh yeah yes and juicy as well yeah
maybe you could have gushers you said I
don't know about that you said that you
had lost your anal virginity not even
that long ago right yeah and it was on
it was on set but it wasn't it never
came out yeah why didn't they release it
I don't know the guy never wanted to
release it a director like we spoke
about this last time I hey though some
huh how did he not release an anal scene
very odd did you see it I don't know no
I never saw it but everything was so
great lingerie was super sexy my baby
was really when could there have been
due to mistakes maybe there was no dude
a little Lincoln hat on it I think it
was supposed to be more like a POV like
the old brown beret I never go to the
bathroom so I don't know oh I see I see
you don't do that stuff never never pee
sometimes in people's mouths when I get
pissed off I see I see when you get
pissed off they get pissed on exactly I
see that's a good philosopher it is yeah
so would you like to hear my rap [ __ ] on
people's door and doorknobs well last
time you hear have you spoken to that
gentleman again no he's [ __ ] dead to
me well last time Mary was here she had
said that the night before she was not
kidnapped
no but she had a bad interaction
somebody an umbrella over an umbrella
and she found dog [ __ ] on near his stoop
and rubbed it all over his door sure so
that's over done and over with now
you're dealing with a guy who's
kidnapped you yeah he can't maintain an
erection he's downstairs waiting so
right stalker
with a soft penis would you like us to
give you some protection to go
downstairs with no it's okay I'll kick
his ass before he even doesn't he I have
no doubt I have no doubt okay well Mary
you went out on the streets of New York
City to Anthony with Anthony yes
although it sounded like this was more
Anthony chaperoning
Mary Jean doing the Mary Jean thing yeah
that's what it felt like right yeah
Anthony's great he's so like my
cheerleader I'm his cheerleader
eventually I want to see his [ __ ] one
day so you would like to
yeah we saw Adrian's I did I even felt
it and how many fingers did you put up
there that's right that's right nearly
eight but he made me take the he said it
was like - not that his [ __ ] didn't
get wet you know right so wet cuz Adrian
our old producer he said it was two
fingers and Mary Jean her story by the
way has not changed honey not that many
years no and it was she said it was two
fingers but also a fist at the same time
yeah so what fist in two fingers yeah
yeah sounds right
I love that [ __ ] so you that's really
great I [ __ ] love that just I mean
yeah it gets me still wet cuz it feels
like a [ __ ] inside wow I had no idea I
went to the doctor and got a finger up
there yesterday the dentist and I did
not get hard oh but it was just she was
just checking me up - have you ever had
no disrespect to just thank you but um
have you ever had your [ __ ] licked I
have not and I really know I told you
that before it's not that I still but it
still stuns me every time and I forget
right right no it's not I'm not I'm not
into analingus I look like a put your
finger inside your own [ __ ] no no I
doctor did and everything was checked
out just fine cuz I heard Troy stuck his
finger once in
sigh his ass how I was listening one day
that's right once right feels good I
don't like my own finger it doesn't feel
like a someone else's finger or a tongue
but not my own thing once is incorrect
Roy a couple times I don't know doesn't
really do much for me
did I get your dick hard yeah that would
be something yeah I've had a girl girl
stick fingers up there it's always nice
but not for you
everyone so why are you kind of mood to
do something a little wild right now
that's not my go-to would you let Mary
put seven you know Tori got a tit job I
heard he got lipo that's right I got
Claire sculpt let me see your titties be
like boss be like laws this choice in
pretty good shape
oh I see it I see this guy was there
before it does look better I see
absolutely hard yeah Troy like snip away
the issue with Troy Troy what does want
to get his nipples removed because
they're permanently hard he's very
insecure about them I wouldn't either
they get your dick really hard time you
touch them I die here my nipples drive
me crazy his Donald you think of a [ __ ]
about his nipples he had he had nipple
rings torn out so now there's scar
tissue yeah traumatized
yeah I'm really hard and people stare at
him and I'm really Bob Travis you like
your nips licked
yes he does let me text Lisa she'll tell
you the same how about you Anthony like
nip play now here's no no he likes
[ __ ] pleasures he does troy was
messing with a with a big fat police
officer at a White Zombie concert in Los
Angeles and the officer Torres nipple
rings out yeah yeah right she sounds
like my kind of girl or guy
you start your nipples Troy it's Chris
Farley constantly staring my god forbid
they're hard in a picture people
everybody has to comment and you're
insecure about that anyway I just come
on like I hear it I know it so next time
you see trying to phone don't bring it
I'm not all my show steps not bring it
up don't bring it up Troy's trying to
turn over a new leaf scientist you know
they make it tough yeah I know I get it
I get it
well Mary Jean went out to kind of get a
pulse I don't when you say my name
Mary Jean mmm-hmm she went out to get a
pulse yeah and she went with Anthony who
Anthony was was talking about how he
kind of did he was your cheerleader he
coached you he relaxed you yeah we went
out for a drink before always better
he made you remember that you're a
champion he made me remember that
everybody's [ __ ] gets wet too kind of
thing smart yeah
we're all the same inside our [ __ ]
absolutely there's a finger in our
[ __ ] it's a great equalizer
but it's 100 percent right better than
talking about slavery that's yeah sure
so Mary really went out to talk about
some of the criticisms the Trump has
been taking the brunt down okay and also
she wanted to get to the bottom of the
g7 summit good which I think you know I
thought was an airplane right Wow I was
like what does the plane have to do with
Trump is that because you do I like a g6
exactly so so let's get to our first
interview out there on the street run
with me you're so cute you want to like
answer some questions for me for the
radio yeah where are you from I'm from
the Bronx talk to me what's your name
okay if I could hit pause for a sec it
does sound like he doesn't want to talk
to you no it's not running and you just
ran and heels great so I'm reporting for
Jim Norton and Sam robber shows the
Sirius XM show really two hot guys
talking about sex and coming can we get
that in a promo that's the best
description of the show two hot guys
talking about section coming Mary you
listened to the show pre regularly all
the time I'm your number one fan I'm
your number one stalker oh yeah I know
you are and I really appreciate when
everywhere bad and just I guess I didn't
realize that that's the way the fan base
thought of our show yeah every time I
explain you somebody else I plants here
and I'm like stop it's my thing right
and then you start thing about beating
people's asses don't you not anymore
good for you good for you Gandhi spirit
good in politics
peasant
listen to what I'm gon lift it like oh
let's go left then so Beyonce said well
anyways what do you think about tell me
about our president cuz you're from my
straight I don't really have any opinion
about it's just I know as long as I'm
not like a lot of governments I'll wear
it more of a democracy not a do you
think Trump has two big balls or two
might be a bit aggressive in doing
things like with balls
little balls little balls all your cute
well nice bye babe see here's the thing
a lot of interviewers will let the
subject dictate where the interview is
going okay and that's a mistake
you stay on point he's over here saying
like oh we have a different kind of
government it's a democracy well it's
kind of and you're like this guy's
talking about nothing
what about the balls that's all I wonder
and then he's like trying to avoid the
question and you're like what the balls
you got the answer up that's what that
reporter does exactly good reporter gets
because a lot of times people want to
avoid talking about something right you
know and that's what you did I'm ready
to go to the red carpet I think so you'd
be great on the right I don't disagree
honestly I want to send you because
politics is more your beat yeah I want
to send you to the next Correspondents
Dinner so what with all that is that
right yeah about money around
would you tell any of the politicians
how you felt I will yes of course it's
only right that's right that's 100%
right okay so that guy was from
Australia he was running and you let him
go like a kangaroo kangaroo you gotta
you got the answer right again he was
trying to avoid the the media spotlight
you grabbed him you got the answer and
he moved on and now we know now we know
and we got the exclusive I think so
who else knew that that guy thinks what
that guy thinks about Donald Trump's
balls no one no one he's back on a plane
to Australia right now he doesn't
remember that he did that but now we're
talking about him and we all know how he
feels
exactly all right should we move on to
the next interview my name is Mary Jean
I'm reporting for the Jim Norton and Sam
robber show on Sirius XM we're not
for your question I want it get to know
you what's your name Dion Dion from
where the Upper West Side Manhattan I
get you gave me Brooklyn vibes I don't
know why wait Manhattan Manhattan pretty
cool it's where all this rich white guys
live apparently you got money
all right why are you walking away from
me I want you to get a little closer
okay I'm a little closer now it's okay I
won't buy
don't worry I'll touch you do you think
Trump stick that's really hard
every time people talk about people yes
absolutely they must you get hard when
like a girl talks eeeh
sometimes but not since I got married of
course now marry
okay I believe that you did not like
this guy um he wasn't giving me sex
vibes he was right well you see he was
afraid of accidentally touching you
people get nervous now in this day and
age they're gonna do something and you
get in trouble and when he said where
it's all where all this rich white guys
yeah it's all conceded right a little
bit
like the vibe I'm getting from you in
this one is that you don't like this guy
the [ __ ] up but you know I was already
professionally yeah yeah we're already
in the middle of your interview yeah
that's why I appreciate that you like
she's like but I'm here to do a job it's
not about who you like and who you don't
like it's about getting information or
how much money it's about getting the
information you didn't ask him how much
money he had no I'm about to start
charging people when I'm on the street
smart smart okay do you think about the
president came jang-woo I it's I'll
actually have a kind of prediction I
think he's gonna ask for asylum do you
like that they getting along they're
becoming they're having tea parties
together do you know that today they're
having a tea party they're in England
right now having some tea no I don't
think so
me neither I was just joking cool well
it was nice talking to you hat so did
you notice that I didn't touch you
anywhere right that's how you better
knob Beecher ass gentlemen most of us of
course if not you get a Dominican
beatdown that change quickly I love to
that she never says I'm just kidding no
she's like I'll beat your ass he's like
okay and she's like have a good day now
now Anthony we got you in the back
telling her the name of kim jeong-hoon
I would have suggested against that you
never help somebody when they're looking
for a name okay that's my fault yeah did
you think that it was at any point was
there a risk because this guy seemed
like a douchebag yes or no I was a huge
was there any point that you were
worried Mary Jean might take the [ __ ]
out of this guy she's very professional
guy had like a baron Trump 20:50 shirt
on he was a douche i'ma tell you the one
I'm gonna tell you something Anthony you
know how you're like I know that she
would never beat somebody's ass cuz it's
a show thing she's literally beating
somebody's ass enough as a matter of
fact you know they you know that you
know the guy whose job that you got
mm-hmm Mary Jean punched him in the face
yeah she did she punched him into
Montana that was the end of his tenure
here
I don't remember it's so funny I said I
was in the bathroom during the break and
the security guard that was there with
us at that at that live event I think
was the first year anniversary he goes
like he every time I see him he brings
you up because he's the one you know who
had to help out yeah and I was like I
think she's coming in today he's like oh
really like he likes he thinks it's fun
and I'm sorry that happened I don't
recall right and I was like an you know
what if anything gets out of line with
your fishbowl event that you got going
on I'll say Mary John I'll send Mary
Jean down there to regulate okay yeah
but you know I'm not like that anymore
change for the better
Mary Jean is mellowed yeah I can tell
but she did threaten to kick to give
that guy Dominican beatdown yeah but he
was kind of being out of line he'd been
fresh he was being a little fresh yeah
talking about his money yeah [ __ ] that
guy very good yeah that's so arrogant
that's right we move on to the next
interview all right it's okay I won't be
crazy my name is Mary Jean exactly right
from the beau the pages of Dan Rather
crazy right you think that sound like
Charlie Rose used to try to get his
interview subjects yes come on my show I
won't be crazy don't go to my place yeah
and I'll [ __ ] in the toilet you can
plunge it say my dick you I want you to
know I must warn you about the toilet
it's brimming with fees swimming with
feces I'm gonna hold you by the
moonlight Charlie Rose rules
it sounds like my kind of fun yeah you
Charlie Rose you probably get along who
is he a he was an interviewer but he got
in big trouble for me too cuz he and he
was harassing women allegedly he took a
big dump and his toilet was clogged he
made a pretty girl clean it out yeah oh
I know who he is he allegedly invited
interns over his house to like do our
jobs for him but then would come out of
the shower naked yeah and just kind of
walk around in front of him show his big
dick and then have them clean up his
toilet which was reportedly brimming
with feces yeah that's really Mary oh
that means he went to a good dinner
before a couple of days worth of logs do
you think he knew she was coming on
Tuesday and so starting Saturday it was
time to fill her up I don't know I think
he probably you know what he probably
had her coming over and then he was
[ __ ] he just couldn't get the toilet
flushed he's like [ __ ] all this ask
her to do it right I'll try to hug her
look at the water it looked like a
SiriusXM toilet after 10 p.m.
guys the greatest it takes a giant [ __ ]
and ask a girl to clean it people take
shits here they do marry a lot if I can
tell you something about the guys
bathroom when I was doing those night
shows yeah you remember of course robber
show that's right
we go in we can we go in there and after
10 11 o'clock at night it was a it was
something out of a horror movie every
single night went off I mean feces yeah
toilet paper and blood and [ __ ] and
urine everywhere guys got period I don't
know why a guy with bleeding roids yeah
oh my god which by the way Mary I don't
have any I know you don't the doctor
checked
oh no blood in my stool that's nice let
me see I got a double check it's okay
you could I'll give you the report juice
a lot of times they get nervous
horrifying
yeah horrifying on by Pat have stomach
cancer I'm like oh no oh yeah that's
right so let's get to okay Jim if you
could okay let's go on to the next
interview what do you say it's okay I
won't be crazy my name is Mary Jean I'm
reporting for the Jim Norton in Sam
Roberts show it's on Sirius XM there's
two hot guys with two really big decks
has a big
all right Travis you got enough material
in here Sam probably doesn't a bigger
dick to me I have to say if I come true
I don't know I don't think I don't know
I think Jim's got the bigger the same
thing is that a passion I don't know
very berry have whiskey I don't know
whatever right handsome Rob yes I'm
sorry back to your dicks Sam probably
does a bigger dick I don't think I
thought bet you do I think Jim's got the
Jim Jim everybody knows Jim's got the
hog around here well jim has nice balls
[Laughter]
is that right yum yum
nice and nice and then in a nice tight
sack nice to fall the elds would come is
your [ __ ] coming from your balls or from
like you know how we have mine
specifically here come with smells so
fresh because you have a good diet thank
you very much actually you eat salads on
Wednesdays it's actually salad Tuesdays
but you probably see it on Wednesday
yeah yeah I get that I get that yeah Jim
is Jim is feeling confident right now
because of his testicle compliments no
I'm knocks I think Sam's dick is
beggar's balling out why would you just
made that up in top of your head right I
would throw both of you at the same time
that's smart I wouldn't like that cut
our dicks would rub together that would
creep me out
we won't do it at the same time we'll
both paint a different color on the
helmet and we'll see which one which
color is the farthest in her mouth I
guess that's the way to do it right I
mean that's mathematically that's the
fairest way I think you're so smart
don't really don't tell me to okay
Robert show it's on Sirius XM there's
two hot guys with two really big sex Sam
has a bigger dick than Jim but Jim
really has a bigger dick than Sam that's
better thank you is great I had not
heard the end of that I think there
should be on the back of a t-shirt
somewhere that's me our bumper sticker
yeah Sam has a bigger dick than Jim but
Jim has a bigger dick than Sam yeah I
like that a lot
yeah I think it's great yeah it's very
deep
I love teeth let's go back a little bit
just so we can hear the whole news that
we've got two new problems yeah give it
a Wicklund let's see if we run them all
over the platform we got big fours yeah
what's a big four technically it's two
balls yeah four balls two really big sex
Sam has a bigger dick than Jim but Jim
really has a bigger dick than Sam which
is cool what's so it's so true what's
your name
Matt Matt from where from DC from DC oh
so you definitely know what's going on
in the world with politics and
everything please explain to me what's a
g7 what's going on in this world I know
[Laughter]
some DC just assume that he knows I
don't know it's adorable
it's adorable to me what's a g7 what's
going on in this world I don't know the
economic summit up in Canada that's what
I heard they're getting along Trump in
and Canada now are they yeah do you
think they're gonna be like hey teens
I'm gonna can republic together you just
cross the border like that sounds
unlikely okay that happens but do you
think about Robert DeNiro cursing out
Trump in the middle of the Tonys award
Amen country do you see what happened I
didn't do you know give me a favor
Robert De Niro why
give me something from Goodfellas that's
tough is he in Goodfellas forget about
it yeah that's the only Italian Saint
unlike there's one you just that's what
came to mind real quick yeah forget
about yeah yeah no it's right believe
they probably said that a bunch of times
and Gotti they probably did was it not
good maybe not I want to see it I've not
seen it yeah you got to see it maybe go
with Mary she's gonna be away Wow what
are you gonna be doing again having lots
of sex and coming oh you're gonna miss
the big fun party I'm having all the
people over Saturday at my house oh
really
yeah the radio crew Oh we'll be away
you're working I was sucking dick fair
enough yeah we
you're not throwing another 4th of July
party no I'm gonna be in Vegas for UFC
nice this is kind of that okay next year
yeah next year I'll probably do it in
August to watch my floors are done
that's exciting
we can lay on the floor and have sex
sure yeah the brand-new flip break it in
breaking one either
it meant amazing when you have a friend
that that's the first thought that
occurs to them I'm getting new floors
put in oh we could lay on the floor and
have sex yeah it's a great it's a great
idea but I've just never done it on my
old floor either I've never [ __ ] on my
floors do you think it's a good idea
Mary it's a great idea because right now
it's lifted I guess he so there will be
P underneath the wood but once they're
all laid out nice and tight we can do P
calm [ __ ] anything all that stuff that's
actually that's quite right in the same
cup to shake all right let's get to the
next interview hey guys how are you my
name is Mary Jean I'm reporting for a
radio show called Jim Lauren in San Rob
or strong SiriusXM do you know them guys
are missing out in life you might as
well you know everybody's killing
themself anyways I like that do you know
Jim Norton Sam Roberts no oh kill
yourself I'm so you know against suicide
but by that case it was justice it's
different yeah yeah they don't be missed
they don't know us [ __ ] them they're
missing out in life you might as well
you know everybody's killing themself
anyways now but I don't want you to kill
yourself trust me I didn't mean it that
way they might fire me I'm sorry so this
is the show for Jim Norton and Sam
Robert she's like I like that she
thought poorly of it she thought better
of it kind of immediately it's funny to
try to watch someone back out of it I
hope you commit suicide comments usually
kill you yeah you should just end your
life but I don't want you to cook you
know I don't know what you do I also
like to tell you what channel is this on
she was like Jim Norton and Sam Roberts
don't worry about it they're very hot
guys before I want to know how you feel
what's going on in our political
world's right I mean when it comes to
politics I really get involved like
really what do you feel about Canada not
getting along with like Trump getting
along everybody gets along with Canada
they smoke away there ya know right most
people don't get along with Trump so
it's not a big surprise Oh apparently
very biased yeah he sounds like he's
from DC he does yeah that's a little
that's a little confrontational almost
yeah I don't remember what happened next
though with any chief Trump now well I'd
like remember I told him [ __ ] you cuz he
didn't all like you did tell him to kill
himself yeah yeah yeah he did tell me to
kill himself do you are you Pro Trump or
pro-hillary I'm just doesn't matter
who's in charge I'm doing me at the
other really I was happy when Bill
Clinton was president like everybody was
getting [ __ ] strip club money huh
yeah I guess that was a good thing all
right wouldn't you wish somebody sucking
your dick and your school desk
underneath have you though right where's
your take a heart right now
definitely not oh sure I'm on snap
nounen-san robbed or shown I love it
nice meeting you too I like that she has
the opportunity to promote something she
promotes us always very sweet that's
wonderful
that's one my whole Instagram page XO
Mary Jean XO there goes I kind of forgot
that's right or is it Mary Jean xxx one
of those yeah Mary Jean xxx
yes that's Instagram that's it yeah this
the other one is the Twitter right the
Twitter yeah yeah looks like Mary Jean
xxx yeah um I'm it's all about your dick
Sam I appreciate that very very much I
like Instagram so I like reading about
stuff like that yeah I like when I post
pictures of my dog you always leave a
comment and eggplants
and eggplants the dog way it's a girl
yeah yeah Lyla Garrity is a girl yeah
yeah but stones who knows she gets a
eggplant that's right this is the last
interview are you ready okay okay hey my
name is Mary Jean I'm reporting from Jim
Norton and Sam Roberts show
your name Rory yeah would you like to
answer some questions that I got about
the world's going on all right sounds
good tell me how you feel where are you
from oh my god you definitely love that
gang bang [ __ ] it's Philly a big gang
they known for that yeah they're right
there I have a lot of gangs out there
oh no but you said gang bang well I
meant sexually of course cuz you know my
mine is right a little off so I feel
like I feel like here's how I think your
mind works Mary Jean and exactly right
but tell me if I'm wrong I think that he
said Philly you first think of gang like
oh you must be in a game
yeah but then when you say gang you
think gang bang so you're like I should
say gang bang that's what might as well
is that the way your brain works
they get it right yeah I got it right
yeah I think so just a little bit did
great right there's more to me but who
really wants to hear about all the other
[ __ ] you know right what do you want to
hear about coming hard dicks wet [ __ ]
wet [ __ ] right doesn't matter what
does it smell like when somebody comes
out of their [ __ ] your favorite
animal in the whole wide world a baby
donkey that's right I forgot
thank you wild at all smell yeah a baby
doc you know baby not a new not an old
dog now debate that's all come that's
right okay let's get back to it really
oh my god you definitely love that
gangbang [ __ ] really no gang bands
really black fur or faux fur yeah Halle
like you're not in a gang right now no I
work actually oh it's too bad for you I
love drug dealers again my [ __ ] wet all
the time
what is it about drug dealers the key
life
the fast life they have money right have
we for me for free it's exciting it's
it's a thrill you know you're going out
with them having that that's thing in
your mind oh my god my god am i safe am
I gonna die am i right
am i getting free weed you know am I not
is the guy that with the soft dick that
kidnapped you is he a drug dealer now
he's a lawyer huh yes I was exciting at
all well he has a job like a real job
got money right I I don't know I have an
accent
but I guess you hear right yeah exactly
right let's continue you definitely
sound like a gang banger now sounds like
you'll be like in the crib I'm a form
I'm a former gang bang do you ever see
Goodfellas yes good line from go fellas
give me a pasta dish line forget about
[Laughter]
really really really well done